tyler malley on the hill for the reds
tonight the 25 year old right-hander 6-3
210 fastball cut fastball curve and
split finger frankie lindor who homered
last night will step to the plate here
comes a 2-2
got him swinging on a breaking ball boy
what a good pitch that was from tyler
o'malley two down in the inning well
shane bieber who's pitching better than
anybody in baseball takes the baseball
tonight for the indians no score in the
bottom of the first
two gone in the first for nick
castiano's the one pitch
straight away
castillatos deep to center field and it
is gone
11 straight games now with a base hit
for castillanos
and that is his sixth home run the first
run allowed by beaver this season
by oh my is he smoking
one-nothing reds and i'm mean to tell
you he
hit the snot out of that thing
suarez is off to an absolutely brutal
start as he pumps and fires
and a swing and a miss good breaking
ball in the dirt and that takes care of
suarez jesse winker stands in nobody on
one out here it comes
strike three called he took a fastball
at 95 down the middle
here's freddie galvez switch hitting
shortstop adding left-handed
now the set
and the o2 pitch
strike three called looking at a
fastball not sure what the reds hitters
are looking at
but they have struck out five times in
the first two innings
here's jose ramirez walked his first
time up switch hitter batting
left-handed
here's the set in the one-two delivery
oh he just blew a fastball at 95 right
by ramirez
back-to-back strikeouts for maui five
strikeouts for mali
carlos santana oh for one
indians at first and second two down in
the third red's on top one to nothing
barnhart is going to set on the outside
corner and here comes mali
lifted high into the air into center
field
sinzell back shy of the track he's got
it
another scoreless inning for the
right-hander tyler malley and the reds
lead this one nothing jordan luplow will
step in
luplow lined to right his first timer
there's the one-two to lufflow swing and
a miss and mali has fanned six through
his first four shutout innings against
the indians one nothing red's leading
man suarez really struggling at the
outset
three for 36 with 13 strikeouts
suarez swings it's a high fly ball well
hit center field backing up mercato at
the wall goodbye
for the first time this year after 49
bogs a year ago
hey you haneo suarez is homered for the
first time in 2020. suarez takes bieber
deep and the reds have a two-nothing
lead jesse winker the batter
struck out his first time up
here's the 2-2
breaking ball swung on in line to
shallow left center reaching up making
the catches mercado
two down for carlos santana he is over
two switch hitter manning left-handed
three-one pitch to santana
this ball smoke to right nope got it off
the end it'll hang up and casteano's
drifting towards the line in the corner
makes the catch
and santana is out the indians down one
two three against mali who has posted
six shut out any kyle farmer a
right-handed hitter gets his first
at-bat this evening the mustache left
the game with a bruised
left wide
now the wine by bieber and the 2-2
swinging a shot on the ground a third
near the line backhanded by ramirez jump
throw over
to first in plenty of time nice play at
third
by jose ramirez the bases are loaded for
cesar hernandez oh boy the 2-2 offering
swung on a weak chopper on the right
side gloved by bottle the flip to straw
bernandez
beat it out and the indians get on the
board
jose ramirez steps to the plate he's got
big power and the bases are loaded a 2-1
reds lead at the moment leans in for the
3-2 pitch to ramirez
it's ball four and the indians have tied
the game
and now the game is tied to two for
frankie lindor switch interbanding
left-handed sims back to the belt
and a tamper to the right side votto has
it under hands to sims and they will get
the out
goal ahead run at second base now two
down and freddie galvez will be the
batter
bieber checks second he'll come to the
plate
and the pits swung unrolled on the right
side into the shift lindor the indian
shortstop has it throws out freddie
galvez
and bieber puts up a zero
here's from mio reyes oh for two
before he batted last stunning he
reached on an air
the big man awaits the 2-2 here it comes
there's the ball hit well deep center
field back is senzelle at the wall he's
out of room it's out of here
finally a big blow for the indians and
it's rodney reyes with his first home
run of the season
and the indians take a four to two lead
top of the order now for the red shogo
akiyama bat
the next pitch
and it swung on him
got him to chase the breaking ball
akiyama is bieber's eighth strikeout
extended his hit streak did castiano's
back in the first inning with his sixth
home run of the season
now the 2-2
another curve and strike three called
castiano's got nothing but curveballs
and he's out looking
here's jose ramirez batting right-handed
signal given the 0-2 pitch and it's a
swing and a liner caught it short by
galves
and galvez will just alertly throw to
farmer at second base just in the event
it was not rule to catch so the indians
still with the runner at first two down
for frankie lindor and like the two
before him he's batting right-handed
chops one past the mound galvez gloves
throws on the run in time what a play
galvez racing in
to field that slow chopper and the
inning is over davidson stands in
batting for jesse winker
hand is set at the belt
the lefties pitch
straight three called fastball on the
inside corner at 93 miles an hour ball
game shane bieber is three and oh and
the indians get a huge come-from-behind
win